belle bonjour el banna bien bonjour car
oui je me suis dit jean-pierre mitraille
alors dimanche qui cabinet dimanche 28
octobre sakai journée internationale
glory élan créole les langues créoles
parce que ni diverses parler créole à
dans le monde et l aile quand même donc
qui sévit en âge pour l'ancrer dans le
matinik metea soutient tout un programme
tout ça mais déjà pouillon dit nous ça
ça y est elle est le cas m qui donc
c'est un collectif quant aux cadis en
français coincés en liant nage peut
commencer
voilà bien elle est quand même s'il y en
a qui entendant qu'il est mort à deux
reprises et associations et puis
plusieurs pipi caca do ba tan en tout
couleur
les associations qui ont des liens à
genoux ni la n 4 900 associations car du
bâti alentours kilti danse et des câbles
matinik à et ap lcf six ans
l'association professeur de langue et de
culture régionale d'auxi momagri cas du
matin l'école la coordination la route
d'el niño si l'association est 4
instituts kilti accueillons nos niqab
burqa badass bel/leo lincoln uni
calebasse le la caraïbe
karim du si un crime a checké yole des
cinématiques a écrit match et en créole
semble âge pouffer langue créole
et puis les mapipi qui ont dit non même
si daniel boukman messieurs andy bell et
daniel de bain messieurs daniel bardou
initiés georges henri lotin et puis
messier s'est joué ce tome nous nions
l'association que jeune le ballon à
temps c'est l'association qui a conquis
ses calibres que yole organisation alors
elle est le cas il n'y ni aux actions
que notre café c'est un travail pour
palancher langue créole nous un pouls et
rapper en plus grand respect c'est ça
notre caddie et puis pour ses moulins
qui cap à l'oeil ou qu'il ait balayé ben
y frapper plus fort ça c'est
effectivement une des aspects que d'un
travail nous nous ni aussi comme
objectif du gorille des outils cueilli
des outils pour chaque que cela
n'occasionne faisait chaque corps de
métier ni des manières pour installer
coyola ne travaillons pas ce que nous
préférons une fois que je le sais pour
parler seulement paie sa vie à tout
niveau la vidéo
et quand le journaliste animateur radio
ni le moment il n'aura fait des efforts
c'est pas créole on l'aria seulement
c'est à dire créole paypal et à dans les
bureaux dans les rédactions les studios
radio conques a dit amélie combattre
toute association toupatou faut que
younes est mana labinot sheholli qui
cache véritablement un lien des pépins
techniques qui nous lie qui nous valent
et s'ils n'ont qu'à observer en compte
les la campagne électorale qu'a ouvert
bags centrale raul my com ainsi les
modèles des tribunes en avance et celle
sur l'a64 sardou savent qu'ils maniaient
fait moi pour me taper plan mon choix
car nous savons qu'à toucher un million
de café quand même si bien que ça m'a
dit personne mandela d'une course à la
montée en ligue 1 adam lang que johan
bonnaud et qualitative quand et où mais
là je dois payer bien la maternelle et
48 ans et sa fondamentale et c'est à
partir de là qu à tout travail ni un âge
pour langue que yom ha tinh base il
savourait 1 et 3 l'un des canaux
résister et de putois l'année
nous mettons nous à chaque année c'est
imité en place un travail semblait
toutefois ski 80 en tout cas parce que
ça pas normal que fait mon niveau pays
nous qui nie tout ça ben là aussi éclaté
bon ça avait failli partie concert
aujourd'hui jouit tan nou camp mais de
tout l'association toute mon équipe pour
adam effectivement najlae en off et
fausses en effet face il s'installa que
d'image 28 new river effectivement
mettez ça ajoute nous a avoué avant
dimanche d'études dépit mois salle comme
daniel a commencé nous révèle une caille
palais dire que ça dit programme aux
autres mais il ya des mots anglais la
jeunesse la jeunesse martinique en
guadeloupe même guyane magnet pas les
créoles à puyoô parce que c'est un
langage qui cac évolue aussi en langue a
évolué en tout cas quoique plan câble
oui et je parie que ni descomps occasion
français des influences qui a fait en
créole nous et les jeunes qu à mélanger
anglet jamaïcain dans les chansons et
même les catalans ciu
c'est une phrase il est jeune mais
peuple à qui tu as fait ça avec un gène
la plus facile à fait y va ce qu'il ya
dans dynamique bazian les réseaux
sociaux basé à l'internet basé dans les
médias parce qu'après ça localiser ou et
sinoti cabaye au toutes les saq
effectivement thériault nous fatiguer ni
un message évolution normale ou qu'avec
ça consiste en des dénaturation quant à
josé jours
la martinique est authentique c'est ça
me plaisait années 90 la danse aérienne
la mondialisation en tout cas le souhait
un cri quand ce type de bateau lors ça
normal que les effectivement pagnol au
panier face à bilbao limpide corps
défendant la attaque la caloterie
s'ouvrira et caf oubliez donc ça normal
effectivement donc lannion travail pour
faire la fête avec la caf l'a commencé
avant les neiges dans des maquis
feuillets manière individuelle et nul
autant travel a commencé parce que
normalement c'est remy a créé mon cas
mathieu matinée dans les travées la caf
est à présent et qu'en fait c'est
tellement qu'ils me please wallonie que
yo l'entrée de la maternelle à
l'université
savez vous qu'il ya des marges qui t'a
fait mes mains s'installe à m'imposer en
question à l'énergie jusqu'à
l'université a dans la foulée cola
serait plus souvent qu autrement c'était
le moment le cas quand même parler
français jean-luc fauquenot trouvait à
manier zhouqu yan raballand mettez une
fois j'aurais 10 polisario pouliot
séville alors blanat dimanche dimanche à
l'ats dimanche 28 octobre donc ni
traducteurs et le café trinité adam cas
de bourrage créole et puis donc au 4
juillet en chanteuse chanteuse
martiniquaise jocelyne beroard épisode
qui estimait que son monde qui défont
l'encré là et qu'il ti kréol là aussi
kilti créole martiniquais ne va quand
même d'y défendre a dit qu'à gommer
toute la vie boulons talent pour kilti
pays pour qu'ils tuent caraïbes là et ça
normal qu'un homme était à l'honneur
pour premier forcado car il lui fait
effectivement en action à 100
je since he did you know this quitte à
mentir le tout la dew mathieu touba tout
est calme tout cas et carys j'étais ica
condamné magnette ces moments-là cas ces
villes en créole à temps leur cachant
tout bien d'autres blague a dit il ça
c'est un bug est important pour que nos
élèves et ça ils s'encouragent univoque
fait ça donc c'est vous qui mettez alone
et nous permet de tout nos matinées
dimanches et fêtes mais après midi vini
bamba lanta est venu d'alger d'une
fausse là pour nous connaître tant au
niveau musique cliquer au niveau
engagement à nakiele du pays